yoru is the worst valerant agent in the
game he's loud he's definitely proud but
his utility has left the community
wanting more we have buffs and reworks
coming down the pipeline but is euro
worth the effort is he just
fundamentally too bad to fix
all right y'all before we get into the
video i gotta remind you as always the
like button the subscribe button and to
ring that notification bell if you don't
i'm gonna have to force you to sit
through my presentation as to why i
should voice the syriza in genji and
impact because my campaign starts now
hashtag lisburisa
okay so before yo remains come for my
throat with a clip of their shoddy kill
out of their old let's just all take a
breather okay there is plenty to talk
about with yaru especially with some
incoming buffs that were recently
announced and we are coming up upon the
one-year anniversary of yoru's release
has been nothing but mediocre since his
release yoru is one of those agents that
is really really great in theory but in
practice is just not what we wanted him
to be i originally went into this piece
with the intent of defending guru but
the reality is i can't do that the more
i looked into both the numbers and the
anecdotal evidence the more the
criticisms of him looked incredibly
valid people's issues with him have been
the same since his release because
they're not something that can be easily
hot fixed they lie at the very heart of
the agent it's difficult to balance an
agent when its core identity just isn't
working so we're going to get into what
exactly feels so wrong about your but
before we do that first we got to talk
about he's not just a weak agent he's
actively shunned by the community
like people hate when you picked a yorun
ranked in every single rank yoru has one
of if not the lowest pick rate as you
climb the ranks he mostly gets lower and
lower his highest pick rate is an iron
which was 6.9 percent when i wrote this
in silver his pick rate is 4.1 percent
in immortal it's 1.6 and in radiant it
is 0.9 so as the players get better the
less and less of your vc and maybe like
subrosa suggested in january this should
have been expected so you're certainly
isn't getting much love from the player
base the question is why the answer lies
in his utility simply put it's not
consistent with what he is supposed to
be
a sneaky duelist that is hard to pin
down defensively his blind and ultimates
are good yet slow tools that when used
properly can be great assets but where i
find the most issues are his gate crash
and his fake out his gate crash slash
teleport
loud like really loud
you can send didn't get out of trouble
but that doesn't change the fact that it
is so loud it ruins the elements of
surprise so the enemy team are able to
change positions and handle the
relocation to be fair to riot in patch
2.06 they did change it so that quote
the range at which the gate crash
fragment is revealed from stealth
decreased from seven meters to four
meters but it is still loud and proud as
it goes by i'm sure you've all had those
moments of like just like hearing it as
it goes by and having to deal with it
when we try to hold the site and it
sounds like wow
behind you
that's a pretty good eurotp impression
no
wow
his footsteps fake out really obvious
like when was the last time you fell for
his fake footsteps as we'll touch on
later the success of yuri's utility
depends on repetitive action towards a
believing aka gullible team like at this
point falling for his footsteps feels
like you are about playing yourself more
than your wizard playing you
congratulations you played yourself all
in all your was not the stealthy sneaky
agent that he is described to be
japanese native yoru was able to create
gaps in reality itself so that he can
sneak into enemy territory unnoticed
strength and stealth allow him to take
enemies by surprise they will not even
have time to understand where death came
from uh
no not really so if he doesn't utilize
stealth
what is he in my opinion a duelist not
the duelist that he is supposed to be i
think this reddit post explained it best
that he's just not sneaky quote yours
abilities don't perform well in what
people would consider stealth you can't
get behind someone just with his
abilities alone without them knowing and
then getting sneaky kills instead you
can get behind them with them knowing
you're there and overwhelm them with
your flashes and ability to reposition
quickly
even though yoru was intended to be able
to get past enemy sightlines and flank
his current kit clearly shows that he is
not supposed to be stealthy about it in
fact his buffed flashes allow him to
make some loud plays and get impact
kills to be clear all isn't lost with
yoru especially if you main him and have
all his skills and timings down you'll
constantly clap me again but not
everyone is a skilled one trick some
people just want to hop on and play yoru
like they would with some other agents
without having to master him making him
accessible to a wider audience is
imperative if we're going to increase
his pick rate and make him competitively
viable this is an agent that competes to
be picked against jet reyes reyna and
sky
it's just not close folks but do you
know what is close the holiday season
and we partner with our friends over at
predator gaming to make sure all of your
holiday needs are covered take it away
danny
[Music]
hey guys danny here from the score
esports and this is my holiday gift
guide i'm looking to upgrade my monitor
it's a big decision because let's be
real there's no point having a high
power pc if your screen just sucks
that's why i've got my eyes set on the
predator 27 inch monitor from the xb3
series seriously it doesn't get better
than this for me we're talking 2560 by
1440 resolution the refresh rate comes
in at 165 hertz and no space is wasted
with its edge-to-edge screen for me
there's just no point upgrading anything
else in my setup until i get this
monitor it just makes everything else
look better
a bit like me
i'm kidding
not really
[Music]
but have no fear because not all hope is
lost we got a fun little surprise on
december 9th when a state of the agents
all about yoru was released in this riot
said that quote yoru becomes a master of
deception through an increased output of
disinformation from round to round
goru's payoff dream plays seem to only
happen after rounds of conditioning the
enemy which can leave him ineffective
for longer than we'd like then they
shared just two of the changes that they
are working on with uru first the fake
out aka the fake footsteps will also now
include a copy of yoru running forward
that is kind of like a phoenixal quote
upon getting shot it will wind up and
explode debuffing the enemies and the
second thing they talked about was his
gate crash it's quieter it's faster and
now a player has an option to trigger a
fake teleport from a distance with all
the bells and whistles of a real one
[Music]
make no mistake these seem like really
big changes
seems like riot has been listening to
quote a character producer john gossake
quote as y'all experimented with him
many of you hit the conclusion that his
outposts were not on par with the rest
of the roster we took the time to really
look at what yoru should be offering
give them more different tools to bring
to life an effective version of the
fantasy y'all have latched on to and
that is everything they are willing to
share now which is exciting and they
said everything's subject to change so
hopefully that means things will get
even better here's ethos who streams
valerian for nrg and his thoughts on the
tp buff so just having the fake tp isn't
just about like oh look i can make fake
tp i can make fake tp plays now
it's about what that asks the rest of
his kid and
it adds a whole lot and it has a whole
lot of more deception
and makes him a lot stronger and it's
going to make those uh sick eurotp
outplay clips a lot more viable because
every time you do it now
the enemy's gonna have to think like is
this guy actually doing it or am i about
to get like shot on the side of the head
all in all these are just proposed
changes and there's no guarantee that
anything will be final but if they look
anything like this there could be a lot
to look forward to in the new year with
yoru the concept of yoru is great
ballarat needs a stealth agent which is
why they created him hopefully these
changes can bring him more in line with
their original vision of him what do you
all think i would love to hear your
thoughts and insight and honestly i'm
not trying to be facetious because like
let's say you are your romaine or you've
been playing balance since the beta or
you're on the right dev team whatever
your experience with ballerin is i would
love to hear your opinion on this
seriously either way we have to wait
until next year friends but who knows
maybe 2022 could be the year of yoru but
until then happy new year and stay
beautiful
is he just fundamentally too bad to fix
some people are
i can fix him no you can't girl
the question is
why
i'm italian i'm just so popular
hello it's not your i don't care
but have no fear
for not all hope is lost
i'm from the 1940s
i'm sorry